hello my name is amritha Chima i'm from
deutsche welle television and i was
moderating a World Economic Forum DW TV
debate looking at sport and the debate
was called going gold gold and growth
how can Brazil leverage to important
sporting events the world cup in 2014
and the Olympics in 2016 in Rio to spur
economic growth and social inclusion and
get a very interesting debate most of
the participants focused on the benefits
of these sporting events and talk less
among actually the costs involved in
focus a in hosting these events and
there's a lot of literature up there it
shows that the impact of these mega
sporting events is often a
misrepresented but the benefits are far
less then one would actually think now
we had a kind of interesting debate on
this and what we really came up with
that the opportunities for resile are
amazing it just depends on how the
country manages these opportunities and
also manages some of the risks involved
in the hosting social event because
after all their lives national spotlight
well these events take place and that
can be a good thing and if things don't
go well it can also obviously create a
negative image for the country we also
talked about one really important aspect
is how support can be used as an
instrument of social change so any kind
of sporting event of the scale with the
World Cup or the Olympics needs to have
a loader social agenda so that all the
benefits that you get from these events
are moved oddly spread out and
just just a benefit one city or one
region of one sector but is it wider
wider population of growth whether its
economic or social so that wasn't the
end what we discussed and let's see what
happens and in the meantime I wish
Brazil all the best and a very
successful endeavor in making the most
of this potential